Speaker 1: Donald Trump has been looking for a
new defense lawyer even as late as this morning,
just hours before today's arrest, booking and
arraignment. This is unbelievable stuff. Report
from The Washington Post. Trump Scrambles to Find
Lawyer before first federal court appearance.
What is happening? Donald Trump spent the day
before his historic appearance in federal court
scrambling to find a qualified Florida lawyer
willing to join his defense team as he faces
the Justice Department's first prosecution of a
former president. This is yesterday after touching
down in Miami Monday. Trump spent the afternoon
interviewing prospective lawyers and meeting with
his legal team, along with other top advisers,
to discuss the case in which, as you know,
he's accused of mishandling classified documents,
obstruction, etc.. Several prominent Florida
attorneys declined to take Trump on as a client
after two of the key lawyers handling the document
matter. Jim Trusty and John Rowley resigned
last week. A Trump adviser said late Monday,
Trump would be joined in court by Todd Blanch, an
attorney handling his case in New York, as well
as veteran Florida litigator Christopher Case. On
the Truth Central platform, Trump said last week
Blanch would lead his defense team along with a
firm to be named later. This is not good. This is
very much not good for Trump. The article goes on
to say Trust in Rowley's departure was sudden and
unexpected, leaving Trump jockeying to identify
a lawyer ahead of today's appearance in federal
court, where rules require practicing attorneys
to be members in good standing of the Florida bar
or be sponsored by one before appearing case led
the search for a lawyer and cast a seemingly wide
net. He declined to comment. The 11th hour flurry
to hire a seasoned trial attorney was a familiar
dance for Trump, who has had difficulty hiring
and keeping lawyers over the course of federal
and state investigations. Disagreements
over legal strategy hindered the search
for new defense attorneys. This is wild, wild
stuff. This is unbelievable. In a normal world,
attorneys would be qualified. Attorneys
would be falling all over themselves to
defend a former president in an unprecedented
situation. But they are probably becoming aware
that when you tell Trump uncomfortable truths
like the indictment is strong or mistakes have
been made up until now and we are now digging
out, or you might have to plea in some way,
Trump probably loses his mind. It's unclear
whether these lawyers would even be able to
get paid. So in a sense, in a situation where
lawyers should be desperate to work with Trump,
it's fascinating that there are even
lawyers still willing to represent Trump,
and it's probably a small subset of people
who are smart enough to pass the bar,
but not clever enough to realize that working with
Trump in this capacity is an impossibility because
of the difficulties in both collecting payment and
getting Trump to actually do what you suggest that
he does, and we've talked before about MAGA
really means making attorneys get attorneys.
That's been a theme as well. The smartest
possible interpretation of this entire lawyer
thing would be Trump is staging a difficulty in
finding lawyers as a delay tactic to continually
be able to have lawyers say to a court, Hey, I
was just brought on. I need a delay in order to
familiarize myself with the facts of the case.
And then you switch again and again and again.
There is that's the that's the most generous
interpretation. There is absolutely no evidence
that that's actually what's going on. This is
a wild situation where Trump is struggling to
find lawyers. Even hours before today's court
appearance will be live for the arraignment
and the arrest and the entire thing on YouTube,
Twitter and Facebook. And I hope you'll join me